hey you guys we're back for another
movie retrospective not going back too
far for this one this is from 2015 and
it is the Kurt Russell film bone
tomahawk that's right
you know I'm deep in the crustal sphere
I like all across I don't like all the
of crosses movies but I like I don't
like them all there's something a little
bit less but you know I mean actually
he's always done a good job in every one
of his yeah even if the movie around him
isn't to it he's always the best thing
in it yeah my favorite once of course
being you know like the thing mm-hmm
escape from New York soldier escape from
LA and bone tomahawks good way now and I
like his Christmas movie you know the
Christmas Chronicles we did review that
like Christmas movie he's Santa Claus
like today this grumpy old sick actually
know he's a badass Anika yeah real
grumpy
yeah he's friendly he's a little bigger
of a yes when he has to be yeah I mean
yeah and he was really good and once
upon a time in Hollywood yeah he shows
up he even does some of the voice-over
with it I forgot all about that yeah and
this is one of crustle uh great movies
from later on in his career this is a
good care of you yeah thing that he's
playing he's playing damn sheriff
investigating the disappearance of some
people well the murder want a black kid
that was in and out yeah he was like
Oliver boy and then guys wife
disappeared and somebody else was
working it yeah the other deputy yeah it
was like this drifter that was in the
jail yeah they were abducted from the
town hall West town you know bright hope
yeah so they call in a guy they call him
the professor yeah
the professor's a Native American guy to
suit a big ol long hair and he knows
everything about Indians see they found
this this weird air is weird arrow
I had like a bone spear head or arrow
head on it so it looked like it was
bummed when I guess it really shut
closed up and this guy tells the story
of you know that
these are troglodytes yeah cave-dwelling
prehistoric horrific Indians that are
like cattle II what do you say he said
they're there they're so bad that they
would they would I think yes I think he
said it was like a tainted bloodline or
something like yeah that was kind of
like the movies way of going these
aren't like we're not picking on Native
Americans these are like supposed to be
like there are monsters really or a
mistress because even like the other
Native American tribes were like yeah
[ __ ] those guys
yeah encrust was like what do they look
like he goes well you you would just
think they were another you know you'd
be in a white man you just think there
were no other Indians but we know what
they are you know or that we know that
you know they're not they're not Indians
they're troglodytes yeah that's exactly
what yeah so they go they go off on this
mission to go rescue the people who got
abducted one of them is dudes wife yeah
he's he's trying to go along on the
mission he's got a broken leg and of
course this is just like you know
everything that could go wrong kind of
does go wrong on this mission to save
these people
it's right here big joke pretty cool
flag there's a lot of good characters in
it a lot of good dialogue crosses
[ __ ] on the top of his game he's good
and I have to say nice and I said this
to him less I mean you know he was
always a good-looking dude when he was
young too obviously but he's like turned
into like the coolest looking old dude
yeah and he looks like something out of
the Old West he does especially like
this especially with this in Reichle
here his mustache in this yeah
glorious yeah I must say but yeah he
really uh you know kind of gets that
across this actually came out I think
this had like a limited theatrical
release in 2015 and then kind of it went
straight to VOD I think like on the same
day that it came out in the theater now
interestingly Kurt Russell also played a
similar role in Quentin Tarantino's the
hateful eight of course which only came
out a few months after this so this like
- yeah kind of westerns now I'm gonna
say right here I've seen the hateful
eight a couple of times it's been a
while since I've seen it I got to see it
again
um I think I like this one better it's
not a movie it's kind of yet
the thing about this one okay now I've
been reading like some different reviews
of it because I wanted to see it has
mostly like you know very positive
reviews you know a lot of people that
thought when it came out it's a Western
for probably about 80% of its run time
but then it goes into like full-on
horror mode yeah and I've seen this
called like it's numerous reviews that I
read it's like house it's like house
4000 yeah numerous numerous reviews of
this have called it the searchers mixed
with cannibal ferox that's pretty
accurate pretty cool like it yeah it
goes like from ambling Western with like
a lot of humor in it surprisingly when
we watched it cuz I've seen it before
but then we watched it again last night
in preparation for the show and it's
actually much funnier than I remembered
like a lot of the it has like a lot of
like gallows humor in it yeah there's
like a you know the assistant deputy
assistant what he calls her the
assistant backup deputy yeah that they
call him
yeah he's I wouldn't call him dumb but
he just he's not real educated you know
you know he just asks crazy questions
about you know how could I read a book
while you were in the bathroom how do
you can to keep the book from kids and
you know crustle comes up with this well
what's what was cross
what was that character's name again
sheriff hunt sheriff hot that's right
yeah sheriff hunt comes up with you know
well you get you put it on those little
music stands yeah like they have it that
Orchestra yeah and then you have then
you have a towel or dry your fingers
just because oh you don't like the old
get anything good think of that you know
chicory that guy say what Richard
Richard Jenkins yeah and really I think
like one of the good acting throughout
the whole damn yeah one of the funniest
things about this movie is the
relationship between those two because
the cool thing about this movie like I
said now this is a very it's very long
it's two hours and 15 minutes or yes
something like that
so as I said about 80% of this movie is
them just like riding to the place to
find the troglodytes and find the PPF I
got to Vietnam yeah it's a mission
oriented movie you know what I mean
getting there is part of the problem and
it would be part of the problem because
you know in the condition that the party
is in one of the dudes got a broken leg
man it's bad now I have to say that um
Patrick Wilson played the guy who's
playing um I think his name was Arthur a
Dwyer and his wife was the one that got
kidnapped
now she was either the doctor or the
doctor's assistant you know what I mean
because she was that's how she got like
ended up getting kidnapped is this
drifter comes into town played by David
Arquette and he's like acting up so Kurt
Russell shoots him in the leg and then
they go to get the doctrine either like
the doctor is drunk and they have to get
the assistant or she's the doctor in the
town I'm not really sure but so she is
staying with him in the jailhouse like
overnight like to make sure his leg
doesn't get infected and all this other
stuff and that's when like the
kidnapping happens so that's how she
ends up being there now Patrick Wilson's
character who is her husband I think he
was supposed to be it's weird because I
see a lot of reviews get it wrong like
they call him the doctor he wasn't a
doctor he was like a foreman or a
construction guy or something like that
and he had been working on a roof and he
fell off the roof like before the events
of the movie and so his tibia was broken
yeah now I don't know how long ago that
had happened it was obviously still very
painful but you know his wife had been
working on it and like trying to heal it
and everything but when she gets
kidnapped
he was will not let the rest of the
posse go without him you shouldn't kind
of understand what it was kind but yeah
he wanted to get his wife back and he
wouldn't be able to you know if I
wouldn't hold her together with him just
stay at home yeah because you could feel
like when himself death so he was gone
he wanted to go on the mission even
though this is legs just like that even
though he prime an eye
that was one of the things about this
movie is that you could tell like all of
the guys that go out on this mission
it's like for guys it's sheriff line
news Kurt Russell it's chicory who is
like the the old doddering hilarious
like backup deputy and then it's Arthur
O'Dwyer the guy with a broken leg and
then they get this other guy played by
Matthew Fox whose name is brooder and
he's like this kind of dandy dressed
like Indian killin dude that like lives
in town and he's kind of like a snot and
he's kind of arrogant yeah
he thinks he's all high class he's been
to Europe yeah it's European stuff he
goes on this yeah he goes on this this
damn mission wearing white too and it
always looks excellent so it's like not
a Lincoln he's putting up trip wires and
stuff around the camp you know so no one
walk up on him and some Mexicans walked
up and they were trying to talk the way
into the camp and they were gonna let
him in he shoots them both dead anyway
- never did find out what they wanted
horses got stolen later on when they
move so maybe he called it right he
thought they were they were just bandits
just trying to talk their way in you
know and but he never really could
explain how it is he knew that it's just
basically says because I'm more
intelligent than you that's basically
well that's he basically says exactly
that yeah yeah the smartest person
yes I'm smarter than all you guys you
know just yeah never really no there's a
bunch of ambiguity in that thing you
know and I like that they like not only
we should have shot that guy he was
wearing across you know and they're just
going back and forth it's just a lot of
good bad or a lot of good characters in
it you know and I like the ending of the
movie with sheriff hunt was like he was
a good character you know know Mandy
yeah he went out like a brave guy he's
right up there with you know McCready
and Sergeant Todd and Snake Plissken and
the guy that he did from hateful eight
you know yeah it was it's that same type
of characters the type of character that
he yeah you want to see the cross we'll
play oh yeah this is like yeah this is
definitely a role that was like
definitely made for him and I think the
thing that makes this work because like
I said you know if you're not super into
westerns if you're not you know familiar
with a lot of the stuff that he's a
moshing like a lot of John Ford's movies
and stuff then you might find this like
a little rambling because like I said it
is very long and it takes like a long
time yeah for them to get to the
troglodytes and a lot of it is just them
kind of going across the frontier like
to get there and like all the kind of
problems they encounter along the way
but what makes this work is the cast and
like the four of them and their
interactions with each other like I said
there's a lot of humor in it
you know not like wacky zany like oh
look at the humor type of stuff but it's
just kind of like a kind of a dark humor
where you know they're just kind of like
trying to make light of the shitty
situation that they're into like kind of
make themself feel better and like for
morale and stuff and I like to that all
four of the men I mean even brooders
character who is initially unlikable but
you do find out as the journey goes on
that he does actually have you know a
lot of the skills to back up like all of
the [ __ ] that he says you know I mean
he's not just some you know God wearing
a white suit who thinks he's all that
who can't do [ __ ] he does actually do
[ __ ] he does actually step up to the
plate and help out and so like the fact
of like the four of them kind of
squabbling but then like coming together
for a common mission I think that's like
a really good aspect and I also want to
say too that Patrick Wilson he's like
you know he's in like a lot of the
conjuring movies and stuff like he plays
what's-his-face you know ed ed Lori ed
Warren in in the conjuring movies and I
like him as an actor but he's he's never
like super stand out or anything but one
thing I really like about his role in
this is that you can just see his
[ __ ] determination the whole time
because his leg is all [ __ ] up you can
tell that he knows that he's slowing
down the rest of the group and you can
tell that he's like really freaking out
like thinking about what's happening to
his wife because it takes them several
days to get there because they lose
their horses at some point they get
stolen so they have to walk and so you
can just kind of just see this gritty
determination he's just gonna [ __ ]
make it you know what I mean and it's
like they they kind of want to leave him
behind at certain points they're like
yeah you know they they don't really
want to but they feel like maybe we
might have to at some stage we might
have to cut off his leg what if it gets
infected so but but you can just see
that like he is just not gonna let that
I think even talks to his leg at one
point he's like you're not gonna stop me
he says to the whip and the movie starts
off with a bang man because you got Sid
Haig in a dam yeah and like a cameo role
yeah
plants pets cuz yes some scuzzy ass
range bandit yeah
yeah and he and his other guy killing
people in their sleeves to steal their
[ __ ] yeah and they run into his damn
trouble dates yeah
and they desecrate their burial yeah
that's where the troubles yeah that and
that was you know so starting off with
sid haig you know he did and he just
hits the perfect note to get the end of
the movie when it starts let you know
what kind of movie this is gonna be yeah
because what they do and I think this is
really kind of interesting and this is
um s Craig Zoller the guy that directed
this this is actually his directorial
debut yeah prior to this he was the
cinematographer prior to that he's a
novelist also a musician and he was a
music writer I think you've heard about
metal mostly maybe he wrote that song at
the very end he did yeah it sound like
some from the 18 he did it's a yeah and
it was it's almost like a parody song
yeah it tells you like the whole plot of
the movie let's call for doomed men
right out or something like that it's
like yet seriously stay for the ending
song cuz he's like it's hysterical it's
just you can tell this was not like a
this is not a real expensive movie - no
it was quite low budget but the thing is
though is that it's very high quality
yeah very well crafted everybody did a
good job and it's and it was presented
as if this is a [ __ ] fantastic movie
you know no I mean like everybody yeah
the coop of it is real and they cared
they cared about the movie and it was it
was up there with any classic I'm saying
in terms of scope and everything and and
up there with any classic 70s you know
yeah western movie you know like Pale
Rider or you know the Eastwood flexes
yeah I mean it does like have a
languorous pace like that yeah it's not
quite same fast pastéis say like Pale
Rider or what's the one where he was
into them High Plains Drifter yeah but
just as effective yeah just as effective
oh yeah definitely I mean it's you know
you could tell that it was made with
care yeah it fits the genre it's very
much a thing of the genre and like I
said when it takes I mean you know some
people might think oh it takes like a
hard left turn and a horror like in the
third act um I don't know if it's so
much a hard left turn I mean they did
you know even though they set it up
that's what I mean like even though
the whole most of the film is them just
like crossing the the frontier they did
kind of like tease it at the beginning
like the very first scene is a guy
getting his throat cut in a very like
graphic and disgusting sound effects
fashion you know by these by sid haig
and you know yet in some ways the movie
kind of reminds you a 13th warrior more
of the I've seen other people compare it
to that you know so much the movie 13th
warrior because I you know like that
movie but the book yeah guys riding off
to go get rid of the [ __ ] few
remaining Vendela you know yeah savage
dudes living in case you know from
another era yeah I have seen very much
yeah and I should say too now okay if
you are squeamish you're you're not
gonna it's pretty cool you're not good
like I said it's it's a perfectly
enjoyable me but like I said if you if
you were very squeamish about gore and
like really nasty kills and stuff I
would suggest that you probably just
keep your eyes handy like right here
like for the for the last third just
okay because there's some nasty [ __ ] in
this and I mean yeah I've seen a lot of
I haven't seen the Eli Roth movie like
his homage to Cannibal Holocaust and
cannibal ferox which is called the green
inferno but I've heard that this was
worse but I'm not sure I think the ones
in green inferno were like more
prolonged but in this one I think the
thing that was bothered me most about
this one was that one it was kind of
like the way it was shot like he shot it
as though you were in the cage next to
Kurt Russell like watching it happen in
front of you so you were in the same in
his in his shoes which I think made it
kind of upsetting and also the whole
scene where I mean if you didn't know
like spoiler or if you don't want to
know but like I said if you're squeamish
and you want to know what's coming this
dude gets scalped alive like right there
in your face and then they also they
take all his clothes off they turn them
upside down and start hacking like right
in between and then pull him in half
like like a [ __ ] wishbone yes guys
come on okay and they drag my different
wreckage
mati yeah then they're gonna eat it so
and that happens like right in front and
like but the something that I think
other than there being not much of a
score and this really helped because you
never really knew what to expect there
wasn't like a big stint like musical
sting when like and era was gonna come
out it was just like surprise you like
it wouldn't rely I guess but I think
something that made this more affecting
was that one the sound effects were
totally gross I mean like they use like
really realistic sound effects like what
a guy getting fold in half would sound
like like I don't I'm not that I would
know but I'm just saying and also the
way that Kurt Russell reacts to seeing
it I think in a lot of cannibal movies
you have kind of [ __ ] like people
screaming and freaking out and stuff
like that but what Kurt does is that he
starts telling the guy who's because the
guys being scalped and he's still alive
and they're still like cutting money and
he's the guy is screaming and stuff as
you would yeah but the Kurt is telling
him you know you know we're the cavalry
is gonna come we're you know we're gonna
get revenge we're gonna get all this
other stuff and like and it really kind
of makes it really affecting because and
then like after they dragged this poor
guy away the the guy that gets bisected
is the is the the deputy from earlier it
was Nick he was like a young deputy like
the up-and-coming one and like afterward
kicker he's like why did you tell him
that that you know the Calvary are they
really coming and he's like no but he's
like I know if that was happening to me
that I wanna yeah so that's what he told
them yeah so this whole thing is like oh
by the way spoiler alert well I'll
probably put that in the description
it's like if you really want to watch
those it's like yeah but yeah I think
what makes it so if it's not just the
Gork but it is very gory but it's
affecting because you give a [ __ ] about
those characters the care the character
that gets killed you don't care as much
about him as the other ones because you
know you he was only in a couple scenes
at the beginning and then he got
kidnapped so you know you're not as
invested in them as you are as the four
guys that like went looking for him but
the way the other characters react to it
like really makes it kind of
heart-wrenching and horrible and then
like all the stuff that happens
afterward again spoiler alert where you
know they
they just the cool thing about it is
that they're just using anything in
there anything they can get to to like
get back at these Hannibal yeah they're
trying to make this gait plan and get
out of there that you know you just got
to see the movie I made Shrek they trick
them they had some damn laudanum
or was it morphine it was OPM opium yeah
they had some of that that helped him
escape they checked a minute drinking
that yeah because the Patrick Wilson had
it for his leg because it had been in
his wife's bag I forgot like a
mentioning the gore there's also a very
gory scene where Patrick Wilson's
character Dwyer cuts the flinger yeah
out of the out of one of the troglodytes
throats yeah all of these things they're
next like so we're debating cuz I don't
think the movie made this entirely clear
what's that a mutation or was that a
body mod I think it might have been some
kind of body modification yeah I think
it was too because I think it was like
because the the trouble is didn't talk
and the only way they communicated was
with it they have like these they would
make my voice horrible sounds like
things whistles and they would like put
them like in their lair annex and it
looked like I mean the effort that he
had to make to cut this thing out of
there since they were kids and it didn't
grow around it that's what I was
thinking because some of them had like
horns and [ __ ] on the face - and I don't
think that was growing out of their head
I think it was nudey they didn't have
any females they just their mothers were
just torsos they had me they were
blinded yeah they had like horns in
their eyes yeah just at least two
pregnant women in the cave yeah their
arms and legs yeah and they would just
use these things as kind of like the
breeding vessels yeah that was like and
I've seen some people say that they
thought that was more disturbing I guess
and I thought really and you know the
cutting people in half the scalping and
stuff it didn't really affect me that
much but I mean however I know I know I
know special special effects when I see
it yeah so you're just like yeah okay I
think that's that was cool it was kind
of but yeah yeah but what their night
when I saw how they were born you know
the minute I was like man they just
keeping them women just you know that's
[ __ ] in the Shelf under sit yeah yeah
when they could have move and they were
just laying there with these big
pregnant bellies yeah it's like yeah it
really kind of liked it were they did
because they didn't really go a lot into
like the troglodytes you know culture or
anything like that but they just had
little bits like that that kind of gave
you gave you a hint of an idea how they
how they came about that gave you like
an idea of what is they were baby
Harper's doing
well they I don't think they could talk
a good talking well probably not if they
did that's anything and they would just
like make these weird whistling noise
because that was like when they were
going across the frontier because they
weren't entirely sure what they were
gonna see when they got there I mean
they knew that they were cannibals and
they knew that they lived in caves
because the professor had told them but
I don't think they were really ready for
that happened when they got there was a
how would you be I mean I think the
professor I think the professor he said
they were from a tainted bloodline I
thought he meant inbred and David yeah
they went dude rape and ether on mothers
so I guess I thought that I thought the
damn torsos they might have been related
to that might have been you know their
family members yeah there didn't seem to
be that many of them no I mean they
killed you know when they killed some
and then they asked um you know mrs.
O'Dwyer which cuz she was in the cave
and she hadn't been eaten yet and they
asked her how many she thought there
were and she thought they were maybe
only twelve males and they didn't rape
her
evidently well um if they did they
didn't say it okay I mean because she
just said because I think that like they
asked her are you okay or you she said
I'm alive that's all she said so I don't
know if that was an implication that
they had been doing horrible should be
this seemed to be they were gonna eat
her they weren't gonna turn her into a
shelf girl I guess yeah because maybe
that wasn't their deal man it's like
maybe they just ate people right and
like the the one it's weird because like
the the stableboy that they killed at
the beginning they were wondering it's
like oh why did they leave him there
like they stole the horses and [ __ ] too
but it's like they why'd they leave him
that they said oh they won't eat black
people that's right the only white
people who said they would be black
people yeah yeah so that's why that
happened because I had forgotten about
that aspect of as well right yeah but
yeah so like I said that's it's gonna be
like a type of thing where if you really
like westerns and you like this kind of
gambling pace that it has but then are
ready for like [ __ ] to get gory and ugly
and then I think this will be right up
your alley
now interestingly there I was I was
thinking about other movies that I could
compare this to other than saying like
Searchers means Cannibal Holocaust which
is cut that's pretty accurate I should
say that this is not the only kind of
Western cannibal movie out there and if
you have not seen the 1999 film ravenous
you need to go get on that [ __ ] that's
actually spent set during the Spanish
Civil War I think and it actually has
more to do with the legend of the
Wendigo um you know the monster that
like if you know it you would turn into
it if you ate people like you know what
I mean so there was a lot of that [ __ ]
about on the frontier like it's a Native
American legend about if you were forced
to eat human flesh then you would turn
into a Wendigo and you would become
cannibalistic so it kind of plays with
that it's also kind of a black comedy
but also a horror movie kind of gory
weirdly David Arquette who was in this
was also in that so I thought that was
kind of weird I'm like that's a very
small genre for him to be in several
movies up so yeah that's so if you
haven't seen that when you see that one
also I wanted to recommend if you like
super violent westerns you should see
the proposition which was directed by
John Hill coat and with a screenplay by
none other than Nick Cave so and it was
badass he also did the score I think I'm
in Warren Ellis also did the score of it
and it's actually very good it's not
really a horror movie but it's it's a
Western but it's like super violent so
if you like this one you probably like
those too as well we probably will do a
review on ravenous one of these days
because I've been wanting to do it
forever I think I have an on DVD
someplace but I think it's also on
Netflix cuz that's also very good and
also has kind of like a dark humor kind
of undertone similar to the way this one
does so you know if you're into crustle
and you haven't seen this one yet I know
we spoiled the whole thing right yeah
but it's still a good watch even just be
ready for the end it's like you know
like I said if you have like a tender
you know make or whatever it is it's
very good and I would highly recommend
it so we will see you next time bye